este es el módulo de vehículo unitario
de khan academy y el objetivo es que
ustedes se familiaricen con las
funciones trigonométricas pero definidas
con el círculo unitario que es una
extensión de la definición tradicional
de soca tohá y la razón de esto es para
poder tener definición del seno del
cociente de la tangente de ángulos
mayores a 90 grados o incluso ángulos
negativos
en este módulo tenemos este círculo con
radiouno y tenemos este punto aquí nos
piden encontrar el seno de menos 345
grados
mueve el punto anaranjado alrededor de
la circunferencia unitaria hasta el
ángulo indicado dentro de la expresión
del seno
el seno según la definición en el
círculo unitario va a ser el valor en g
de la coordenada de este punto así que
vamos a mover esto aquí está el ángulo
como ven es tan negativo tiene un menos
y un valor acá vamos a buscar el seno de
menos 345 aquí va al menos 100
menos 145 todavía nos faltan menos 180 y
lo pasamos menos 270 todavía nos falta
más menos 345 ya nos estamos acercando
40 45 aquí está este es un ángulo
negativo recorrimos el punto en sentido
horario y esta coordenada nos queda su
valor que es punto 259 que es el valor
del seno es que escribimos aquí la
respuesta punto 2 59 veamos muy bien eso
estuvo bien ahora vamos a hacer otro
ejemplo que lo que nos pide el cero de
menos 235 grados otra vez un seno con
ángulo negativo pues como es negativo
nos vamos a ir en sentido horario
arrastramos el puntito y vamos viendo
cómo va aumentando el ángulo
negativo
este es menos 200 aquí tengo 180 aquí
estoy en 200 y es menos 235
ya casi ya casi ahí está y es la
coordenada y es el valor vertical de
esta coordenada 10.819 la escribimos
punto 819
comprobar respuesta y si muy bien
vamos a ver otro problema a ver qué nos
ponen aquí ok ahora es el seno de menos
cinco tercios de pie es un ángulo
negativo menos ok si se fijan aquí está
el ángulo en radiales expresado con pi
vamos a buscar al menos cinco tercios
vamos a ir aumentando menos un cuarto
518 a vos
seguirle moviendo
a ver
tres medios
aquí ya está por acá y está menos cinco
tercios aquí está
la coordenada de este valor
punto 86 6 si se fijan aquí esta es la
raíz cuadrada de 3 entre 2 y entre
paréntesis está el valor expresado
decimales este entonces es el que
escribimos punto 866 checamos la
respuesta y estuvo bien vamos a ver
ojalá no salga algún coseno ah sí muy
bien ya no salió en conocen cinco
tercios de pi como ángulo eso es un
ángulo positivo así que vamos a empezar
a recorrerlo en sentido antihorario en
nuestro ángulo cinco tercios de pi que
es el mismo pero aquí va positivo que el
anterior el anterior era menos cinco
tercios ahora son cinco tercios de pi
aquí están dos tercios
vamos a seguir bajando más más más más
vamos a ver ya debemos estar aquí está
cinco tercios de ti aquí está el ángulo
de interés ahora lo que nos están
pidiendo es el coseno hasta hace unos
momentos lo que nos pedían en el seno
que es la coordenada y en este valor
pero ahora nos piden el coseno y el
coche no es la coordenada en x de este
punto y el valor en x es un medio o
punto 5 lo escribimos acá punto 5
comprobar respuesta muy bien vamos a
hacer uno más para que quede bien claro
esto ahora es un seno pero positiva seno
de un doceavo de pi en sentido
antihorario aquí está es un ángulo
chiquito mundo ciego de pi y como es el
seno de nuevo vemos la coordenada en ya
que es punto 259.200 59 y muy bien
comprobamos la respuesta vamos
ser una más y qué bueno nos tocó coseno
y es más el ángulo es de 180 grados el
ángulo positivo movemos esto en sentido
antihorario y este ángulo es muy
sencillo de encontrar 180 grados es la
media vuelta aquí está a 180 grados
no tenemos coordenada en y está justo en
el plano de las x así que su seno sería
0 pero aquí como es coseno nos piden la
coordenada en x que es menos 1 este
valor es menos 1 y muy bien esa es la
respuesta correcta y espero que con esto
ustedes se han familiarizado un poco más
con este trabajo de los ángulos usando
el círculo unitario nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo